Das Schnitzel,
um das sich zur Berlinale vieles dreht
– Filmstars wie Tom Cruise,
Cate Blanchett, Jack Nicholson, Jessica Alba
oder Robert De Niro schwören darauf.
In Hollywood ist das Berliner Restaurant
Borchardt als „The Schnitzel Place“ bekannt.
Nicht nur zur Berlinale geben sich die Stars
hier die Klinke in die Hand.
Restaurantbetreiber Roland Mary weiß genau,
was die Stars wollen.
Er bewirtet sie und schweigt darüber.
Understatement gehört zum guten Ton.
Keiner von uns mag hier so Monokulturen.
Das heißt, gemischt ist immer gut.
Und das ist eigentlich schon alles.
Und wenn da Stars dabei sind...
Wir wollen die nicht ausschließen,
aber wir machen auch nichts für Stars.
Also, das ist jetzt egal, Mensch ist Mensch.
Vor allem zahlen alle gleich, und für alle ist
das Schnitzel gleich groß, ist also Wurscht.
Im Borchardt gehen mehrere Hundert
Schnitzel pro Tag über den Tresen.
Sieben Tage die Woche von mittags bis spät
in die Nacht:
Rund 100 Mitarbeiter sorgen dafür, dass alle
Wünsche der Gäste erfüllt werden.
Das Schnitzel wird im Borchardt nach
traditioneller Wiener Art zubereitet.
An den Details, wie dem Perfektionsgrad der
Panade, wird aber kontinuierlich gefeilt.
Dass wir das perfekte Fleisch haben,
dass wir Bio-Eier haben,
dass wir ’nen hauseigenen Bäcker haben,
der uns das Brösel-Brot für unsere Schnitzel
produziert.
Das Umsetzen von dem Schnitzel, der [die]
Herstellung ist natürlich noch mal besonders.
Dass wir das in 80 Prozent Butterschmalz
und 20 Prozent geklärter Butter
herausbacken.
Und da ist natürlich wichtig, dass das
Schnitzel richtig schwimmt
und bei der richtigen Grad-Zahl von 180 Grad
ausgebacken wird.
Die Geschichte des Borchardt reicht bis ins
Jahr 1853 zurück.
Zu DDR-Zeiten
war es unter anderem ein Tanzlokal,
nach dem Mauerfall stand es zunächst leer.
Heute steht das Borchardt für Weltoffenheit
und internationales Flair
– und für die zahllosen Prominenten, die hier
ein- und ausgehen.
Bei der Wiedereröffnung 1992 war das nicht
abzusehen.
Wir hatten schon ’n Jahr offen,
da war es immer noch so,
dass, wenn so ’n Trabi
oder irgendein Auto lang … hier langfuhr,
wie so aufm Dorf …Ich bin aufm Dorf
groß geworden, da hörst du ja lange,
bevor du die Autos siehst, hörst du sie.
Das war hier genauso.
Es gab keine Geräusche, es gab keine
Menschen, es war irre!
Zur Berlinale ist im Borchardt Hochsaison.
Zehn Tage lang ist alles ausgebucht.
Wer nicht reserviert hat, muss warten, egal ob
Filmstar oder Kinogänger.
Wir haben bis fünf Uhr morgens Küche und
bis dahin ist auch was los.
Und es ist viel los.
Die Gästeliste des Borchardt: exklusiv wie an
keinem anderen Ort in Berlin.
Roland Mary bekommt sie alle. Und alle sind
heiß auf „The Schnitzel Place“.